and i'm not in any of these highlights
it's like nobody appreciates defense and
rebounding anymore welcome offensive
superstar 2022 wardell stefan curry
oh it's draymond i mean yeah welcome to
the arena outside of space and time
where we have
draymond
green
finally getting some respect who should
we get oh versus two-time defensive
player of the year 1998 dennis the
dennis
damn phil you ain't got to be sending
portals to drag me to practice and [ __ ]
rodman how's your dictator friend oh my
be good a one-on-one matchup between two
defense-oriented players
i'm okay feeling this thanks to eleven
win by two
[Music]
[Music]
we are the point what is this sucker
okay change of plans games now to three
straight out robin soup i'm gonna show
you how doves do it that imaginary
backpack is heavier every year
boom rebound
rodman's left the arena for porto vegas
don't leave me open
all right let's get on with this
[ __ ] i think i married saturn in
porto vegas
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] i do it way better than boxing
[Music]
shoot
friends who get the rebound
one two three four five
and robin wins
[Music]
[Applause]
finally found fans who appreciate my
defensive minded approach to the game
that's enough for me hey everyone steph
is shooting threes from the parking lot